yeah now we need a rating on this video
because it sounds like sex noises wait
at F rated at four I'm here with
Kingsley today this is the first time
that we've met each other it is and I'm
very very pumped I don't want to do a
video for you for life
for so long so long we've been trying to
see each other at conventions it never
happens ever so I've forced him to come
over to my house and I might not let him
leave but that we'll find out but into
the video it is one super Wednesday it's
or a Lulu for sure that's the favorite
thing now but anyway the SAG Awards
happened this past weekend and Kingsley
is a fashion icon so I thought he should
help me judge the fashion I'm wearing a
t-shirt and sweatpants just so everyone
knows it's partly I got sparkles on oh
so that means that they're allowed to be
in public Roberts
yeah that's Julia Roberts shit's like a
piece of salmon there's something wonky
about it I don't know what it is her
face is long yeah it looks like
something happened in the facial area
with tools I like this guy's face in the
background it's her clutch red I don't
know but that's that best bad right it's
bad you can't do that mix shades like
that offensive fifty shades are wrong
something's wrong in the tits area it
looks like her tits are deflated then
drop yeah
the space cadet I can a that's a gift
I'd like to unwrap crazy her legs would
looks massive yeah she's doing a weird
Angelina Jolie leg doing it notice that
- yeah ever since she did that I've seen
legs legs legs legs thighs are in for
2014 oh my god oh my gosh she looks like
an Ikea like display and I can't display
yes you know what the fake living rooms
she looks like the drapes like she's
grimacing it's like she just had like
really angry sex and now she's here I'm
Maisie Williams she's from Game of
Thrones that she follows me on Twitter
and that's why I included and we're best
buds and I think she looks really cute
and really age-appropriate I'm just
gonna agree with you yeah I like this
she looks very like regal yeah simple
and and again yeah but she always kind
of looks like she's holding in a part
she looks like she's like a president's
wife so good job Ellie grant who's that
oh my god what what you know what
scandal No oh my god I'm literally about
to leave I see but Hollywood tweeting
about it all the time I understand it's
probably a great show I'm still on
season three of Breaking Bad Oh give me
a second okay
this girl from Game of Thrones okay she
looks like she's still in game of pool
we're in The Hunger Games what is that
it's like he's afraid her what it's
biceps like these things are gonna fall
off no the paper stuff that you put
inside of drawers so that things don't
slide that's like sticky stuff yes yeah
that's what her arm things look like I
don't like this shape this thing this
isthis no Rianna wasn't the first to do
it but I'm gonna call it the Rihanna
give him a splice
what splice teeth have you not seen
splice know that bald gremlin thing that
like eats people
oh I'm learning so many things today
Jennifer Lawrence I don't know it looks
like someone fell like sparkly trash
bags all around her body and covered it
in saran wrap it looks like she's stuck
in the middle of a laser tag arena I
love her though why'd you choose it's
like I don't totally hate it but there's
something that's not good about it it
gets her no shape yeah it looks like a
long fettuccine new wall yeah that got
gross after years of sitting in the
refrigerator
moldy yes it was there Mariah Carey was
bad why
this is Kerry Washington oh my god yeah
why did it happen on your body like that
I am very offended I wore something very
similar to this to homecoming in 10th
grade
and then we kicked out not a real human
being like this looks like a wax thing
here she is crazy yeah she looks like
she is the Chrysler Building we get it
you're gorgeous
that's right can you see underwear am I
am I looking too hard I think you're
just projecting on your hopes God but no
why the hell can't Blanche it's more
like a blanket why is that blanket
hanging from your neck I know it looks
like like she's half of a bird yeah if
you went to her other side there be
another flap and she could just fly away
it looks like her neck just puked and
that's all of our review of the SAG
Awards fashions on the red carpet
Kingsley overall well what were your
thoughts I think that a lot of these
women put the [ __ ] and [ __ ] oh but you
were going to the SAG Awards Oh like a
dress oh yeah what about you I would
wear nothing oh you get a lot of new
subscribers I think on your channel from
that I think that's a solid choice
Kingsley thank you so much for being
here make sure that you go over in
Kingsley Sean though because we shot a
video that is super fun and funny and
educational Kings is all about at the
end of the day
I don't know this is the girl from
Modern Family I don't know her name but
she is not a little girl anymore
definitely not those tits are on full
display I feel gross I don't know face
looks like a little baby and then it's
like that is Wow melon I know we were in
the fruit Department of whole food her
clutches what